You know what last year you didn't even
have a job now you've got a job next
year you've got a promotion right he
might not be there yet
but I guess going back to Pearl's
question what if he was on a genuine
come up like there was proof in the
pudding he wasn't just saying it
can I yeah okay talking from experience
it depends I feel like it depends about
how the person that you are and where do
you want to go yourself because
personally now I'm really driven trying
to open my business I had two business
with my ex-boyfriend been together four
years blah blah let's do this together
blah blah blah perfect I wasted time
say that we build the two business
together now I'm leaving them and you
know when you do the meeting to draw
someone out
so you did so imagine like maybe you're
thinking now for what I want to achieve
in life because I'm there I want to open
my business you know I got a few like
business plan there already on the table
um waiting for
um some
investors to put some money in I would
love to have some money already that is
there because my ambition and my drive
once someone does already know that can
like help me out for the come up do you
know what I mean someone is working for
it it's not 100 sure but it depends on
the person that you are though I feel
like if you guys are really loving you
believe in each other like you know yeah
probably both of them but personally I
would be the old demand that's really
there you'd be the older man okay yeah
can I just add on Twitter ease as well
um
so
when I say like if I want to date a guy
that's on the calm up we have to align
so I know I'm dating you to marry that's
where the Common Ground will be that's
why communication will be key also I'm
not necessarily gonna give my all to him
we also have to have that understanding
that I need time for myself to better
myself also I'm not gonna date somebody
knowing that I still need to work on
myself I need to work on myself first
before I start dating and then when I do
come when we do come together it's like
we can help each other in a way where
each other has helped us as a woman I'm
a Christian I understand that the man is
the leader he's the head and then I'm
the helper and I've got to submit and
not when people hear the submission
thing they think of it in the wrong way
when I say submit is just be there for
him respect him and support what he says
I'm the neck he wouldn't be the head
without me so I'm just as important so
we also have to like communicate well
and know that okay menu Dayton is for
this purpose to marry so I'm not playing
about because that's where I'm at this
stage of my life I'm not just dating
today so I'm not going to date like five
different men because I don't have time
for that I'm working on me I'm working
on my business the same with him so as
long as we have that understanding that
we are dating to marry and he's going to
come up I'm on the come up then yeah
it's all about communication you said
you're a Christian how many people here
are Christian to show of hands would you
say that the church keeps people single
not necessarily it depends on where your
best and if you you kind of have to have
your own relationship with God as well
that's one thing about being in a good
church because some people you you just
listen to what the past is saying like
literally you fixated on him like
they'll worship Him you also have to
have your own relationship and
understanding with God the main role of
the pasta is to guide you and teach but
also you also have to have that own
relationship with God but they're there
to help you give those nuggets to you
help you grow you also have to grow
within the faith yourself okay that's
what do you think so I think so the
Bible is very clear that that God
intends for Christians to marry other
Christians but uh statistically speaking
the church makes up of
um 70 of of people in the church are
women
um and I think it's like 50 are single
women and there aren't as many uh at
least in the west like where I'm from
Canada the us there are not that many
guys in church so to answer your
question I think in some ways yes based
on the Bible
um yes unfortunately okay yeah I agree
with you
um you know Christian actually I was
raised Catholic okay
um and my mum and dad actually met at
church interestingly enough
but it was interesting when you said
about the pasta and I'm just thinking if
so many people are watching hit
worshiping him
and there's 70 if the stats are correct
as majority women wouldn't he be that
high value man that's kind of that's
right that's what I find like they take
like
I've heard stories on the show where
their Pastor will tell a girl not to
date someone because he's not like yoked
or not enough or Christian enough and
I'm just like okay well so the pastor's
keeping these girls single no and that's
certainly but I just think like results
speak for themselves and if the church
wasn't keeping people single if they
weren't they didn't have some heart to
play and this men wouldn't be leaving
the church and women wouldn't be single
in the church if they were good at
building families but like I'll go to
because I grew up Catholic too and I've
gone to Christian Church too I've gone
to church here and I look around and
took a bunch of single women yeah it is
it's true it is I'm really um happy that
you spoke about submission because they
actually don't talk about that in the
church they don't talk about what it
means to be a woman and what women offer
in relationships and what it means to be
a good wife and a good mom and a and
they don't talk about that at all so I'm
so happy that you you agree and they
also they also encourage men to take bad
deals yeah like and so off oftentimes
they'll encourage men to have this like
relationship with God be monogamous but
most of the girls in the church aren't
virgins so it's like you're telling them
to be equally yoked but most of these
girls are not virgins in the church and
why do why do Catholic school girls have
such a reputation and Christian School
girls do like two so I I agree with that
because I was I was raised Catholic and
I think where I was I'm not going to
speak for the whole Catholic faith but
we're from how I grew up it was
literally just a list of rules that you
just you just need to follow it because
this is what the word says and in some
ways that's true but it wasn't until I
stepped away from the faith for a short
period of time until I actually had the
context of why those rules are in place
God made you he knows you more than you
know yourself he knows every hair on
your head so he's just don't use them as
as God being evil and wanting to oppress
you because he made you he it's view it
as more like he made you and he knows
how you can find fulfillment and
happiness and freedom and avoid more
pain than there already is in life I I
agree with you
um but the one thing like I think they
they preach from a young age is they
tell girls like they'll have a happy
ever after no matter what no they do
because they have these Catholic school
or not Catholic school they have these
Chastity speakers and I've seen
Christians I've seen Catholics and what
they'll do is like they'll be like oh I
was so broken and this girl like talks
about how she like basically she got ran
through and then still found a husband
and like okay that's good for you that
you found it but I can list 10 girls
that didn't happen for and if you make
those choices there might not be someone
to bail you out at the end of the day
and that's like more of an honest
conversation than I was so broken which
one isn't even true you were horny shut
up like stop and like it's not broken
when you just make a poor decision and
go ahead okay
and got these unpopular opinion okay and
probably people hate me for this I was
raised Christian Catholic I don't
believe in the Bible I don't believe in
church I don't believe in but I believe
the majority of the people that blindly
follow these rules is people that have
been indoctrinated because that's what
the church does they found people that
are lost they are not they don't they
didn't find the faith on their self and
the law of God in their own ways so they
have to put all their faith in the hands
of someone else that is absolutely crazy
to me like I will never listen to
someone in church and I will blindly
just do it yes Pastor say this let me do
it that is why there's been so many
cases where the church
reunited all these people and the
pastors had complete 100 power and all
these people that believed because they
lost people they don't have their own
self-esteem enough to be like wait this
is wrong can I have an example I'm just
I'm like this is Broad so I'm just not
sure what we're an example would be
um even like even for girls to have all
these rules and in the Bible there was a
verse I think of maybe evangelo because
I don't know you said that what it was
to like not sleep around yeah they
preach that for men too yeah and they
preach um yeah but not really I remember
I read this it was saying the only
purpose of a woman is to fulfill and
serve the desires of a man something
like that but that was the old one right
now I stopped believing church because
in my church it was people that were
claiming to be nases and racist and
just there look you know in the sense so
it's not the church I believe that
everyone can believe in God in their own
way so do you believe there's something
there but I don't I don't agree with
rules we church with everything because
we see the rules the pastors are the
worst people most most times at least in
Italy more time I do want the pedophiles
they went to jail
um
I think any position that's powerful
leads to corruption I don't think I
don't think the church is special and
I'm not like a Die Hard like I'm not
acting not agree to that like you don't
think that every position that that had
power in all of history has had
corruption like why do you think
politicians always get killed yeah it's
true yeah because when you have power
you're like oh my God I can do this so
then you just do what do you think
Genghis Khan had like 100 like how many
people are related to him
man-made yeah I have a question for you
because you said something along the
lines of the rules and so
in the past right we've always kind of
had at least in the West in England in
the US and Canada we followed
judeo-christian values we our
governments have kind of implemented as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible